there are tons of easy ways you can pass
the time but why not fill your time with
some experiments while you are just
sitting around would you believe that
you can actually walk on raw eggs
without them breaking stay tuned to see
how if you are new to our channel click
the red subscribe button to see more
videos like this today we are showing
you ten fun and unusual experiments to
waste your time on plastic milk what
would you say if we told you you could
turn milk into plastic well you can and
it's very easy all you need is one cup
of hot milk one coffee mug with four
teaspoons of vinegar paper towels and a
spoon combine the hot milk and vinegar
in the coffee mug and stir you will
notice the milk starting to curdle after
the make sure he's cooled spoon the
curds out and place them onto the paper
towels to dry press out all the water
and then remove the paper towels now you
have case in plastic which you can mold
into any shape of your choosing make
objects disappear though it may seem
like a magic trick this experiment works
by playing with light you will need a
beaker vegetable oil and one or more
glass objects fill the beaker with
vegetable oil and place the various
glass objects inside you will notice
that the objects become hard to see to
take it a step further find a glass
container you can pour vegetable oil
into and drop it into the beaker did it
completely disappear glitter slime a
great way to kick your DIY slime up a
notch is to add glitter the easiest way
to make glitter slime is to get one
bottle of Elmer's glitter glue one cup
of water 1 teaspoon of borax and an
extra tablespoon of water first mix 1
teaspoon of borax with one cup of water
next empty the bottle of Elmer's glitter
glue into a separate bowl and add the
extra tablespoon of water then combine
the borax mixture to the glue mixture
and blend together with your hands the
mixture will quickly turn into your
pretty glittery slime unbreakable egg
this experiment will allow you to bounce
a raw egg without it breaking all you
need is a glass white vinegar and a raw
egg first place the raw egg into the
glass without breaking it then pour the
vinegar into the glass until the egg is
completely submerged over the next 24
hours you will notice
eggs will start to lose its shell once
it looks completely gone dry off the egg
and try to bounce it from a couple of
inches off the table fish for ice on a
boring day were too hot to fish for
actual fish try fishing for ice for this
easy activity you will need a glass of
water a few ice cubes table salt and a
piece of string drop the ice into the
glass of water and close the string on
top
pull the string out and notice how you
probably haven't caught anything place
the string back in the water but this
time sprinkle some salt on top wait a
few minutes then pull your string back
up and admire your catches magnetic
slime there are several DIY slime
tutorials online and magnetic slime is
one of the coolest to make your own you
will need liquid starch Elmer's glue
iron oxide powder disposable bowls and a
neo diem magnet for 1/2 cup of liquid
starch into a bowl add 2 tablespoons of
iron oxide powder and then stir next add
a quarter cup of glue and stir until
well mixed the slime will start to form
you can take it out and start mixing
with your hands which may get dirty get
rid of excess water with a paper towel
and start playing with your magnetic
slime and neodym magnets ivory soap
monster this experiment lets you make a
crazy ivory soap monster as well as your
own soap at the same time all you need
is a dish of water a microwave and a bar
of ivory so place the bar of soap in the
dish of water and microwave on HIGH for
2 minutes now watch as the soap starts
to transform into a fluffy monster wait
for the fluff to cool and then you can
play with the mixture or make your own
soap balls just add your own ingredients
like oatmeal or lavender and let the
mixture dry overnight
fluffy slime if you have a need for even
more fluff try the fluffy slime
experiment for this project you need a
large bowl 5 bottles of Elmer's glue
shaving cream baking soda contact
solution food coloring foaming hand soap
and googan pour the 5 bottles of glue
into a large bowl then add two and a
half tablespoons of baking soda and mix
next add one and a quarter cups of
shaving cream to the mixture and keep
stirring add your food coloring and a
couple pumps of hand soap and keep
stirring finally add drops of contact
solution to the mix until you can play
with the slime without it sticking to
your hands
popsicle stick harmonica have you ever
wanted to try the harmonica but didn't
have the cash to do so try this easy to
make popsicle stick harmonica instead
for this you need two wide popsicle
sticks two rubber bands one strip of
paper that is the size of the popsicle
sticks and two toothpicks first place
the piece of paper between the popsicle
sticks and fasten each end with a rubber
band
then slide a piece of the toothpick
between the popsicle sticks on top of
the paper and on the inside of the
rubber band finally do the same on the
other side but under the piece of paper
now make some awesome music with your
new instruments walking on eggs you may
have never thought about literally
walking on eggshells but it's a fun way
to frighten a boring day gather 6-8
cartons of eggs a trash bag and
disinfectant wipes first make sure there
are no broken eggs if you are indoors
lay a garbage bag down in case things
get messy
next place the full egg cartons into two
rows making sure all the pointed ends
are facing down with a friends help
stand on the eggs with your bare feet
finally take a few steps while keeping
your weight evenly distributed did any
of the eggs break which one of these
experiments are you excited to waste
your time on let us know in the comment
section below and for more fun
activities check out our 10 awesome
science experiments you can do right now
at home
[Music]
[Music]